[Music]
there comes a time in any aging man's
life when you realize that if you want
to age gracefully you've got to start
making some better decisions today I'm
at the yoga LOF in beautiful Manhattan
Beach California to meet up with comedy
legend Bert Kreischer to discover how
beer yoga and a few laughs can be the
magic Trinity namaste so Bert this is my
first time meeting you it's a pleasure
I feel like we are we are in sync
kindred spirits right I know that you
were named by Rolling Stone number one
partier in the number one party school I
was voted number two part here at
Muhlenberg College we being serious
Allen town by my peer group as we get
the middle age our metabolism slows down
a bit right everything bagel right there
you can kind of see it only that the
bagel yeah you want to see what a food
cake angel food with little wisps of
saffron for a weekend warrior like
comedy legend Bert Kreischer I wanted to
share a beer that's thirst-quenching
sessionable and low enough an alcohol to
keep that six-pack intact enter see
crunch al an equal parts blend of three
distinct beer styles a classic crisp
kölsch a gos infused with sea salt and a
Berliner Weisse with lime juice lime
peel and black lines for aging beer
loving Yogi's like me and Bert sequin
jail is all the thirst-quenching
goodness that we need this was developed
because I pretty much have to
a little bit at least everyday for my
job throw me in the briar patch and I
was like holy crap as you're gonna [ __ ]
ton of big IPAs and it's like I want to
make a beer that's super flavorful but
run it through the filter of Kim dogfish
Head make objectively the most
thirst-quenching
low calorie beer we've ever made and
still make it intensely flavorful so it
doesn't taste like nothing the way beers
with low calories usually this is a
fantastic beer
thank you and this is only step one in
our journey today burn we are on a
journey take me to step 12 so I can go
home and enjoy my family so this is a
Belgian style beer made with lemongrass
orange flesh orange peel a little
peppercorn nameste means that spirit of
me celebrates the spirit in you and it's
what you say at the end of your yoga
practice so we're gonna be hanging with
a world-famous you know a little bit
later before we do that how did you
first step into yoga as part of your the
machine gets more healthy journey I was
dating this chick I didn't like right I
was just unhappy I was fat I was unhappy
go to the yoga class and I feel a
connection of like sweating and
stretching and really holding a pose and
the guy is walking and he's like what
don't you like about your life right now
and it was clear to me I was like this
how can this girl this girl yeah and he
goes decide to change that right now and
I went I can't change it he goes you
can't change it because he heard the
voice yeah can change it decide to
change it I was like I don't know he
goes just make the decision that you
will make it different today what is
your thing and I was like I want to
break up this chick and he's like can do
it like almost like to me and I was like
a dialogue with your subconscious I felt
a weight off my chest and I went I don't
have to be in a relationship I'm not
happy in and that night I went out and I
broke up with her I met my wife six
months later I lost like 30 pounds all
the 186 pounds with my wife
bait-and-switch but that one yoga class
changed my life and then we did sober
October me Segura Ari Joe Rogan we did
15 hot yoga's in a month
we're gonna circle back to the yoga part
of our journey today okay but that's in
the future the next phase of our journey
we're gonna go a little bit back and see
what some some tastes and smells remind
us of in our past all right you ready
for the next part of the journey I'm
ready it's gonna be like a Rorschach for
our palates I like this this is gonna
take us back in time immediate
impressions I'm not going to tell you
which beard is until after we've enjoyed
this to go the beers inside yeah and
then and this is our okay got it
I'm an idiot you're gonna tell me what
it reminds you some moment of your past
love what you're doing right now okay
it's gonna place into all my strength
okay okay you ready beer number one
where let's do this
smells like it's coming out of the keg
it's freshly nose my freshman year
smells a little bit like a mop yeah it's
not the cheapest of the cheap but it's
not expensive I don't know what it is
are you ready time to find out the first
beer that we had today I guess okay yeah
sure sure natty light okay let's see how
close he is people an American classic
Pat's Blue Ribbon yeah that reeks of
everything I said
[Music]
not too aggressive it's got the same
head I'm gonna guess Budweiser right off
the bat give me a memory this time
instead of it being you in a situation
what if this beer was a car what car
would this be mmm this car smells like
gasoline when you sit in it and someone
got pregnant in the backseat they would
listen to John Cougar Mellencamp yeah
what parking lot were they in like can
you give me hold on a parking lot there
in a field field a big cherry blossom
and they get hot and heavy right in heat
and then he is a romantic he goes back
to the trunk pops it and he had a cooler
of ice cold this beer it's gotta be Bo
Hwa's about like let's see guys you
ready happen in a field I'm like a
detective with beers dude I have had so
many hams you never knew it was gonna
happen but you knew your night was
ending right it was either a fist fight
it was you guys listening to little Boz
Scaggs this branding this can that's a
beautiful can really is a beautiful kid
and the branding hams hams
hams heart is a [ __ ] that's what
it stood for you for us oh we're going
hard as a [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh
cuz had to ends yeah him set you off
that was a critical bear haven't had ham
just so long as it I almost know what
the third one's gonna be hmm let's see
[Music]
clean palate your strong Minds can't
lose I'm not I'm not smelling what I
thought I'd smell okay I just caught it
yeah I know I have to know what this is
I have to know what this is
well it's gotta be I've gotta be
anything but but you know the Beast do
you want to reveal it's gonna be safe
oh my god no no you know this beer this
is the beer that wrote all the songs I
love oh my god cuz it's a grunge era
dude
I was gonna say it smells like teen
spirit you just made me see something
from the other side of the fence mmm
this whole hipster profile that has
taken over beers where this is all of a
sudden cool
of course it's [ __ ] cool look at this
can mmm look at the horseshoe there that
front bro it's they're not trying to
oversell you we do what we do
did you come to a Bert Kreischer show
he's taking his shirt off he's getting
drunk he stole the machines Dora yeah
it's the water look at that it's the
water they can't all be fun and games
again we're at a moment in our
middle-aged life let's face it
we're we gonna get physical let's get
physical we know that we are in a
beautiful house of yoga yeah and we
actually have Ryan a world-class yogi
and he's gonna take us on the next step
of this journey for the next step of my
journey is time-traveling I haven't
thrown up hams in like 30 years
you mean throwing up your hands and wave
them though he thrown it up by downward
dog style let's get into this
[Music]
bring your ass together prayer in front
of your heart take a nice little glance
at the beer imagine what its gonna feel
like tastes like going down the back of
your throat and go ahead and crack that
bad boy open oh you - Jeff started a
tradition that is the best sip of a beer
I've ever had when you appreciate it and
slow it down and you're not just trying
to kill it and race to it that's life
that's yoga you know you want to slow
everything down and be in the moment
pure yoga have come together in classes
pretty much globally but what has not
happened is a move a signature move the
blue steel of yoga poses for beer
drinkers and that's the journey the
three of us are on right now
[Music]
all right we got to name this this is
great beer Sherry's little Hacha pasa
pasa pasa birria and here's the press
about a possum Alana pass pass the beer
asana possible Ross enough passive
Barossa no passive vajrasana passive or
asanas
so we actually proved our point tonight
people we proved the exponential powers
of marrying that magical Trinity of yoga
drinking laughter
[Music]
you